So let's see if we understood inclusion.
Let's say that we have a level one and
level two cache that
maintain inclusion property.
Let's say that the dirty block is
replaced from the level one cache
by something else, and
we need to write it back.
This write-back access,
can it be a level two hit, and
can it be a level two miss?
So check here.
If the right back axis from
level one can be a hit in L2,
check here, if the right back axis
from L1 can be a level two miss.
Now let's look at the level one and
level two cache, but
this time, they make no
attempt to maintain inclusion.
Again, if we have a dirty block
replaced from the level one cache,
the level one cache
has to write it back.
This write-back, can it be a level two
hit and can it be a level two miss?